welcome back it is time for today's
morning cup of joe
with metro sheriff joe lombardo good
morning sheriff it's great to see you
good morning alex good to see you you
know deputies with the la county
sheriff's department they are now going
door to door administering the coveted
vaccine to the most vulnerable
is something like that possibly going to
happen from metro
you know you caught me at a loss with
that question i'm not real sure
the program is presented i'd have to do
a little bit of research but
i can uh probably give you a pretty good
answer associated with it so it
you know to administer something like a
vaccine
some medical training has to be on board
with the individual ministering it and i
would anticipate they're using
certified emts that's within their
workforce to conduct that
all right sheriff metro is working right
now to recruit more minority members to
the force can you talk about that effort
i know there was just an
event a couple of weekends ago and how
that outreach is going
yeah that's a constant battle for us
because i've said it publicly in the
past alex that the police department
needs to look like it's community for us
to be successful and it isn't
you know where you're going to have a
hispanic officer respond to a
hispanic call for service it's just
understanding of different cultures and
the education that goes along with it so
an officer knows
by interacting with other officers of
different demographics or race or
culture
they know what to expect on a call for
service it's a it's a learning mechanism
and you can only achieve that by having
it look like the community we're getting
a lot of viewers writing in saying
they're noticing more cars with no
plates or their tags are just expired
has that become a growing issue for
metro
um not per se because the depart the
officers have been educated on that
particular issue
and and and granted or unlicensed
vehicles and
unregistered vehicle usually when a
vehicle is unregistered it usually means
they don't have insurance too so
that that's a big issue if they're
involved in accidents especially if you
are the victim of an accident but the
officer has been educated with that gap
in the system and the dmv gave people
some leniency
i believe it was in 90 day increments
and they did three different increments
along the way
but right now you're required to have it
your vehicle fully registered
yeah do you know sheriff at this point
what percentage women make up at metro
police
unfortunately females are not 100
percent
attracted to police work so if you look
at our civilian population
our civilian employees versus our
commission employees so policing versus
administration or support uh we're at 50
50
um in that percentile and that's pretty
close to
the clark county demographic but when
you go into
the corrections and policing side that
that number
completely changes and so women make up
around 18 percent
sheriff thank you so much for all the
work metro does we appreciate it and
thanks for joining us so early
hope you got your morning joe all right
have a great week
if you have a question thank you for the
sheriff you can submit it to us
on eightnewsnow.com and find out if your
question was answered
every wednesday